-Hello, everyone,
and welcome back
to the attic crawl space.
And, of course,
the mystery remains.
I know you've all been
thinking about it --
the tiny door.
What is it?
How'd it get there?
Why would an architect build
a door of that size
into an otherwise
normal-size house?
Or maybe it is
a normal-size door
and I've simply been
12'0" tall this whole time.
You can never tell on TV.
Or maybe, you guys, maybe,
it's a Malkovich door.
I won't confirm or deny,
but let's just say
if you ever tune
in and see John Malkovich
doing "A Closer Look,"
someone please come pick me up
on the side of the
New Jersey Turnpike.
Look, I know you're
all wondering,
so, if you have any guesses,
submit them to
whatsupwithsethstinydoor
@gmail.com.
Maybe we'll read some
on the air; maybe we won't.
Who knows?
Honestly, we might never
even check that email
and you just have
to be okay with that.
It's a pandemic.
There are no rules.
And, hey, while
you're speculating
about what's behind that door,
the president is speculating
about an unproven medical
treatment for coronavirus
after ignoring repeated warnings
about the threat of a pandemic.
Segue!
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
[ Suspenseful theme plays ]
Seems like, almost every day,
we get more and more evidence
that the Trump administration
knew well in advance
of the very real threat
of a pandemic
and that they both ignored it
and lied to the
American people about it,
despite the fact
that the president
keeps saying stuff like this.
-Nobody could've predicted
something like this.
Nobody knew there'd be
a pandemic
or an epidemic
of this proportion.
I just think this is
something, Peter,
that you can never really
think is going to happen.
It's an unforeseen problem.
What a problem.
Came out of nowhere.
We're having to fix a problem
that, four weeks ago,
nobody ever thought
would be a problem.
It's something
that nobody expected.
I would view it as --
as something that just
surprised the whole world.
-It's very telling
about his psychological state,
that, when he means "I,"
he says "nobody."
[ As Trump ]
Folks, nobody coulda kept
a casino open in Atlantic City.
Nobody really blew it.
Nobody sucks!
So, nobody coulda
seen this coming.
Yeah. Taiwan and South Korea
and New Zealand and Singapore
were all surprised.
That's why they have a combined
total of 12,000 cases
and we have a total
of 400,000 cases.
Although, in fairness,
New Zealand had a huge advantage
because they could call in
those eagles
from the end
of "Return of the King."
And, I'm sorry, guys,
but where the hell were you
this whole time?
You're tellin' me
Sam and Frodo spent three movies
climbing Mount Doom,
fighting giant spiders
and getting stabbed
by Ringwraiths,
and, this whole time,
they just coulda hitched
a ride on a giant bird?
Oh, what, you don't do direct
flights from Hobbiton?
You guys are less
reliable than Spirit.
Although, [ Laughs ] I forgot
it was called Hobbiton.
Hey, J.R.R.,
what are you gonna call
the part of the shire
that Bilbo lives in?
"Oh, I don't know. I was
thinkin' maybe like Hobbiton.
Oh, I don't know
if Hobbiton's good.
It sounds like a little lazy.
No one's gonna think I'm lazy!
This thing's gonna be like
a thousand [bleep] pages."
Hobbiton.
Anyway, no.
This did not surprise
the whole world.
Just because it surprised you
doesn't mean
it surprised the world.
Everything surprises you.
Even your own speeches
surprise you
because you so often
are reading them out loud
for the first time, which is
why you do that weird thing
where you're both reading
and doing a DVD commentary
on your own speeches.
[ As Trump ]
We will be sending aid
to all 50 states.
50, wow.
Wow, that's a big number, 50.
Wasn't always 50.
He's like a guy who walks
into a birthday party,
when everyone yells
"Surprise!", said,
"Wow, we are all
equally surprised.
I can't believe
we all got lured here
under the same false pretenses.
Did you guys also think
this was gonna be
a quiet dinner for two?"
In fact, at one point,
Trump even claimed that,
despite notable pandemics
that have occurred
throughout history,
like the 1918 Spanish flu,
nothing like this
has ever happened before.
-So, there's never been anything
like this in history.
There's never been.
Nobody's ever
seen anything like this.
-Stop sayin' nobody!
People who were alive in 1918
have definitely seen
something like this
and I'm pretty sure your friends
would like all of them.
[ As Trump ] Wilbur, tell me
what the Spanish flu was like.
[ Creaky voice ]
It was horrible.
We had to subsists
on a soup and a beer.
Good thing I was over 21.
That's not a Photoshop.
I went on TV
and had soup and beer.
In fact, Trump keeps
vaguely mentioning
the 1918 flu pandemic,
but, for some reason,
he keeps getting the date wrong
by exactly one year.
-Nobody's seen this.
I would say, since 1917,
which was the greatest
of them all.
Probably the greatest
of them all, right?
1917.
There's been nothing like this
since probably 1917.
That was the big one.
You read about 'em.
You read about 'em from 1917
and you read about 'em
from lots of other times.
-[ As Trump ]
So, I may have been late,
reacting to coronavirus,
but I was a year early
on the Spanish flu.
Of course, no one writes
about that, do they?
So, I think I know
what happened here.
Trump knows there was
a movie called "1917."
He thought those guys
looked kinda sick
and just assumed it was
about the Spanish flu.
Of course, they're not sick,
they're just British,
which Trump would know, if he
hadn't turned off the movie
to watch "Rugrats."
And, yet, despite Trump's
repeated claims
that no one could've
foreseen this,
it turns out a lotta
people foresaw this.
Including people
in the Trump administration.
Here's just a quick list.
First, Obama officials
walked Trump aides
through a global pandemic
exercise in 2017.
Then, in 2017 and 2018,
threat assessment
intelligence analysts
even mentioned a close cousin
of coronavirus by name,
saying it had
pandemic potential.
Then, in 2018,
the director for medical
and biodefense preparedness
at the National Security Council
told a symposium
that the threat of pandemic flu
is our number one
health security concern.
Then, top administration
officials said last year
that the threat of a pandemic
kept them up at night.
Then, White House
economists warned,
in 2019, a pandemic
could devastate America.
Then, intelligence reports
warned of coronavirus crises
as early as November; and then,
U.S. intelligence reports
from January and February warned
about a likely pandemic.
Well, you know the old saying,
"Eight strikes and you're out."
Seriously, how many incredibly
specific warnings do you need?
This is like gettin'
a note that says,
"I know what you did
last summer.
Specifically,
you hit a man with your car
and then, you
and Freddie Prinze Jr. decided
to hide the body
and pretend it never happened.
And now, in an act of revenge,
I'm going to systematically
stalk and kill each of you,
one at a time.
I am also sending this via email
and will copy all
above-referenced parties."
[ As Trump ]
I don't know what that means,
what any of that means, but,
I think we should all go
camping in the woods.
I know a great place
with no cell service.
In fact, in this White House,
if you plunge your head
in the sand and ignore reality,
you can actually get rewarded.
Case in point, yesterday,
Trump appointed campaign
spokesperson Kayleigh McEnany
as the new White House
press secretary.
In February, over a month
after our first confirmed
case of coronavirus,
McEnany said this...
-This president will always
put America first.
He will always protect
American citizens.
We will not see diseases
like the coronavirus come here.
We will not see terrorism
come here
and isn't that refreshing,
when contrasting it
with the awful presidency
of President Obama?
-If you think goin' from this...
to this is refreshing,
then you might not know
what that word means.
Trump looks like
the physical embodiment
of the feeling you get when
you fall asleep on the couch
and wake up after dark and you
don't know what day it is.
The only thing refreshing here
is the Kool-Aid you drank.
If Trump's gonna hire people
who go on TV
and say things
that are that wrong,
he might as well hire this lady
as the secretary of Knowing
Who Greta Thunberg Is.
-A 2019 book entitled "No One Is
Too Small to Make a Difference"
is a collection of speeches made
by a Swedish
climate change activist.
What's her name?
-Sharon.
-Agh! So close.
First of all, I love that woman
and that clip will never
not make me happy.
Second of all,
Sharon is such a bad guess,
for so many reasons,
the least of which is how
not Swedish Sharon sounds.
[ changes accent ]
These are my friends,
Elsa and Ingrid and Sharon.
Anyway,
after all those warnings,
on Tuesday, we found out
about yet another warning,
when it was reported
that Trump's trade advisor
warned the White House
in January
of the risks of a pandemic.
And, at the top
of the document he wrote,
it literally says
"Memorandum to president."
Of course Trump has probably
never even heard the word
memorandum before.
He probably saw that and said...
[ As Trump ]
I can't read it.
It's in Latin.
So, they knew,
and they lied to you.
They told you it wasn't
a threat, but they knew, it was,
and they put lives at risk,
not to mention
all the economic carnage
they knew was coming.
They knew.
Here's another part
of the problem.
The guy who wrote that memo,
Peter Navarro,
is also a crank.
It's what happens when
an oatmeal-brained sociopath
guts the civil service
and surrounds himself
with fringe right-wing weirdos.
Even if someone's right,
you don't know who to believe.
For example,
Navarro, a trade advisor,
has been one of the loudest
voices in the administration
pushing the unproven malaria
medication hydroxychloroquine
for coronavirus.
Now, Navarro has
zero medical expertise,
which led to this exchange
on CNN on Monday...
-My qualifications, in terms
of looking at the science,
is that I'm a social scientist.
I have a PhD and I understand
how to read statistical studies,
whether it's in medicine,
the law, economics,
or whatever.
-I-I-I'm sorry.
That doesn't qualify you
to treat patients.
Do you want an internist
striking trade deals
-Heh. Touché.
-with Asian countries?
-[ English accent ]
"Ha, ha, ha, yes!
Touché, sir.
I doff my cap to you, sir.
On the question
of this potentially dangerous
and unproven medication,
you have checkmated me, sir.
Well-played, old chap.
Bravo.
These guys are so easy
to outmaneuver.
It's like playing tic-tac-toe
with someone who doesn't realize
you're supposed to make
a straight line.
[ English accent ]
Looks like my O's
have all four corners.
"No, I beat you in three moves."
Touché, old friend.
Beat me, you have.
If you're wondering how
somebody like Navarro
ended up on Trump's team,
in the first place,
according to Vanity Fair,
at one point,
during the campaign,
when Trump wanted
to speak more substantively
about China,
he gave Kushner a summary
of his views
and then asked him
to do some research.
Kushner simply went on Amazon,
where he was struck
by the title of one book,
"Death by China,"
co-authored by Peter Navarro.
He cold-called Navarro,
a well-known trade deficit hawk,
who agreed to join the team
as an economic advisor.
You know, we give Jared
a hard time
for havin' no skills
or expertise,
but in his defense,
he has Amazon.
Dude probably rocks Google, too,
and here I am,
givin' him a hard time, sayin'
he has no idea what he's doin',
when he's probably
Askin' Jeeves as we speak.
And Trump has followed the lead
of his grifter friends
and allies
in pushing hydroxychloroquine
over the objections
of Dr. Anthony Fauci,
who said we need clinical trials
to prove it's safe
and effective.
For example, it could have
potentially lethal
side effects on the heart
and, yet, Trump has brushed
those concerns aside.
According to The New York Times,
Trump made a rare appearance
in the situation room on Sunday
as his pandemic task force
was meeting,
determined to talk
about the anti-malaria medicine
that he has aggressively
promoted lately
as a treatment
for the coronavirus.
Once again, the experts warned
against overselling a drug yet
to be proved a safe remedy,
particularly
for the heart patients.
"Yes, the heart stuff,"
Mr. Trump acknowledged.
"Yes,
the heart stuff."
Thank you, Doctor.
I can see Trump walkin' in
to give a patient the bad news.
[ As Trump ]
Listen, Jim, I'm afraid
it's, uh, heart stuff,
and that's extra bad because
you know you have that, uh,
lung thingy.
It's clear that,
because he ignored
repeated warnings
about this horrific situation,
Trump is now hoping
there's a miracle cure
that will get him off the hook.
Just listen to him
selling hydroxychloroquine
in a bizarrely hushed tone
at a White House
press briefing on Saturday.
-And I hope they use
the hydroxychloroquine
and they can also do it
with Z-Pak,
subject to your doctor's
approval and all of that.
But I hope they use it because
I'll tell you what, uh --
What do you have to lose?
There's a possibility,
a possibility,
and I say it, what do you
have to lose?
I'll say it again --
what do you have to lose?
Take it.
I really think
they should take it,
but it's their choice.
And it's their doctor's choice,
or the doctors in the hospital.
But hydroxychloroquine.
[ Airily ]
Try it, if you'd like.
-My God, is anyone else
creeped out
by his tone of voice?
I feel like he just pulled up
in a windowless white van
across from a high school.
[ As Trump, hushed ]
Hey, kids,
I got some hydroxychloroquine.
It'll make you feel sky-high.
Try it, if you like.
Also, there's heart stuff.
Trump is desperately hoping
this will all just go away
and that's why he's pushing
an unproven miracle cure.
This morning he tweeted that,
once this deadly pandemic
that cratered
our economy is over,
it must be quickly forgotten.
But it shouldn't be forgotten.
Our government,
led by our sociopath president,
ignored repeated warnings
that a major public health
and economic disaster
was headed our way.
And, if you point that out
to Trump and his supporters,
the best they can
counter with is...
-Heh. Touché.
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
♪♪
City Harvest
is such a great charity
and, now, they're working hard
to support
New York City families
who are outta work
due to the COVID-19 pandemic.
If you're watching this
on YouTube,
please hit the donate button.
Stay home. Stay safe.
We love you.